moi je pense thaïs avec toute l'estimé
que j'ai pour vous j'espère réciproque
qui en fait votre ennemi c'était votre
diffusion dans cette émission
ce qu'objectivement moi ça fait
longtemps que je vous suis de par mes
combats et que je vois déjà les
ratonnades médiatique et numérique que
vous faites sur les réseaux sociaux vous
avez une plate forme qui vous supportent
qui s'appelle twitter ou quand vous
chassez des gens n'y a qu'à voir ce qui
s'est passé une semaine avec le maire de
trappes qui aujourd'hui par vos
collaborateurs et quand même menacés de
mort jamais menacé vous yacine
maintenant moi quand je passe ici là je
sais que pendant une semaine savoir le
droit ou à des modèles pour aller au
bout juste pour aller au bout oui là si
c'est quelque chose je pense que quand
on a fait cette émission les gens ont
découvert de manière même stream parce
que c'est le cas de cette émission ce
que vous faisiez mais je pense qu'il ya
un côté icare dans votre association ne
pouvez pas dire devant des gens
notamment un avocat pas vu pas vu pas
pris maintenant vous avez vu on vous
prend vous parlez du ccf et de barak a
city je pense que moi j'étais totalement
contre la dissolution de ces
associations qui sont comme vous le
dites de manière juridique il n'y avait
rien d'illégal
c'est votre sentiment de croire qu'ils
sont allés avec des actions terroristes
par contre vous ce que vous faites c'est
chasser des immigrés sur le col du
montagne où aller au dessus de la mairie
de de la caf de bobigny et dire faut
virer les étrangers après de dire oui
mais le jugement est en cours c'est vrai
mais là où je rejoins l'avocat à côté de
vous qui me dit quelque chose qui est
assez plausible
je veux dire que la séquence est
tellement redoutable aujourd'hui que
même quand on veut pas parler de vos
petits exploits on est obligé et
vraiment je vous dis la vérité
aujourd'hui le merde le maire de trappes
qui est menacée il ya plein de problèmes
à trappes
il ya plein de soucis c'est pas le
premier des livres où était écrit non
mais je suis là mais juste pour aller au
bout d'os et le prix et vous dire les
choses des fois qu'ils sont des faits
qui nous ce que vous amenez sur des
plateaux et qu'après on fait la vierge
effarouchée en dix ans mais pas du tout
moi j'ai eu votre le patron de votre de
la génération d'auditeurs qui m'envoient
tout je suis plus sur twitter j'ai été
viré c'est quand même saint-élie réussi
à 10 qui dit qui disent il m'avait eu en
face de lui parlerais pas comme ça mais
je rejoins la phrase de cyril un déjà
vous fait peur à qui et 2 vous vous
prenez pour qui
parce que si aujourd'hui vous voulez
mettre une armure comme au moyen-age
avoir un glaive et décapité les
sarrasins vous pouvez aussi le faire
après je vous cache pas que c'est
difficile d'augmenter dans le métro avec
une armure mais il faut justement
redescendre il ya des lois il ya une
justice on essaye de reconsolider les
liens aussi avec une police avec qui on
a pu avoir des désaccords mais tous les
policiers sont papouasie on essaye de
construire mais vous a créé pour
détruire et vous voulez quelque chose et
anaïs dit que le bois dans les yeux ce
que vous fantasmez c'est non pas de
sortir avec un arabe ou un noir mais
vous fantasmez l'idée d'une guerre
civile avec dakota et les musulmans et
de l'autre côté vous comme les gardiens
de la patrie mais ça je vous le dis pour
faire une guerre faut être deux non vous
aurez pas vendre bien que les à gérer
mais alors vous attendez sur les quotas
il se répand chez les solis mais je suis
quand même toujours assez mal à l'aise
avec le fait que vous puissiez me faire
la leçon
mais son moral alors que je sais que
vous avez quand même été interpellés
nombreux soit vous avez sûrement vous
avez été inculpée pour harcèlement moral
de nombreuses reprises montrées pendant
les deux à l'étoile sempot judiciaire
nous n'avons pas été condamné mon nom
mais effectivement sous ça un petit peu
culotté de vote pas mais non mais vous
êtes vous allez quand même pas meilleur
que moi aujourd'hui et quand ça mais
vous allez quand même pas que ma mère
déjà faire non mais excusez moi là je
vous réponds ne prenez pas vraiment pour
acquis les fiches des gens qui sont
derrière nous parce que je vous le dis
moi je peut vous poursuivre si vous dit
quelque chose qui n'est pas vrai lâchés
en face de vous restez sur le sujet de
savoir à partir de quel moment vous
pensez que faire des ratonnades dans ce
pays est autorisé par génération
identitaire c'est ça ma question mais
que là vous dis depuis deux semaines
darmanin maintenant aujourd'hui de
vérifier le tir moi je n'aime pas
darmana je vous dise droit dans les yeux
je le trouve islamophobe
je trouve même que c'était une séquence
incroyable de voir marine le pen lui
dire que le problème c'est pas l'islam
c'est l'islamisme
par contre ce qu'il fait avec vous vous
avez raison c'est un enjeu politique
à partir du moment où ils tapent sur
certaines associations il doit réguler
avec vous donc maintenant selon certains
c'est balle au centre
je trouve que c'est une mauvaise idée je
rejoins certaines personnes là qui
disent non je trouve que 10
n'est pas une bonne idée mais le
gouvernement s'est mis tout seul dans
cette impasse la alors moi aujourd'hui a
pas de passe droit aux jo